quiero que recordemos un poco historia
de nuestro país historia económica
regresando al año 2000 cuando tuvimos en
ese entonces pues una realidad que era
global que era realmente complicada
porque pensamos que el literal del mundo
se acababa llegamos al 2000
no teníamos sino problemas en asuntos
tecnológicos como el white ok por
ejemplo y pensamos que realmente el
mundo estaba llegando a su fin y en el
ecuador vivíamos una realidad bastante
complicada tuvimos problemas dentro de
nuestro de nuestra economía días grises
en los que vivimos pues la desaparición
de nuestra querida moneda el sucre así
que tenemos en esta mañana un
recordatorio de esa historia y de la
realidad que pues tuvimos que vivir en
ese en ese entonces y para este
recordatorio y recordar justamente el
día en el que ecuador se dolarizó vamos
a invitar a wilson ver a quien
representa una amplia trayectoria en el
sector público específicamente en el
banco central del ecuador como en la
academia como profesor de política
monetaria en la maestría de economía del
instituto de altos estudios nacionales
además del profesor en varias
universidades y en el centro de estudios
monetarios latinoamericanos hoy son ver
es doctor en economía por la universidad
complutense de madrid- maestro en
economía por la facultad latinoamericana
de ciencias sociales y economistas de la
universidad central del ecuador además
de autor del modelo de estimación de la
oferta monetaria de una economía
dolarizada así como varios libros de
macroeconomía del sistema financiero y
de pobreza demos un aplauso a wilson de
anna para esta presentación
gracias
buenos días para todos
en la noche del domingo 9 de enero del
año 2000 cuando los ecuatorianos nos
prestábamos para descansar y reiniciar
nuestras actividades de la siguiente
semana hubo un anuncio en cadena
nacional de radio y televisión del
presidente del ecuador de ese entonces
yamil mahuad que decía que el ecuador se
implementaba el esquema de dolarización
oficial y él manifestaba que a partir de
esa fecha nunca más se iba a emitir
sucres pero porque se dolarizó ecuador
porque el dólar fue sustituyendo al
sucre en sucre tuvo hasta ese entonces
una vigencia de de 116 años a partir de
su creación en 1884 es decir inclusive
antes de la creación del propio banco
central del ecuador cuáles fueron los
factores claves
para la dolarización si fue la
dolarización previo a partir
efectivamente del anuncio del presidente
mahuad o fue un proceso más bien
ciudadano que se dio años atrás si la
dolarización ya estuvo dada a partir
solamente del anuncio requirió un tiempo
adicional más yo me voy a referir a
algunas claves que dieron paso a la
dolarización pudieron haber muchos
factores políticos económicos externos
pero mi presentación mitad la se va a
centrar solamente en aspectos monetarios
y de índole de la moneda a inicios del
año de los años 90 había mucha oferta de
dólares en el mundo que requería buscar
donde obtener rentabilidad y esos
capitales fueron fluyendo al mundo y
ecuador obviamente también hubo espacio
para eso ecuador justo en los inicios de
los 90 hace varias reformas a cero
formas de la ley del banco central y
mediante las cuales efectivamente se
permite la libre movilidad de capitales
a cesc y los capitales pueden entrar
pueden salir al ecuador y su hijo
coincide ese caso
entonces otro elemento clave que se da
para la dolarización es que las
operaciones en dólares de aperitivo
antes de esto eran prohibidas las
operaciones en dólares cuando las
familias los hogares necesitaban que sus
hijos vayan a estudiar al exterior que
ciertos miembros de la familia
necesitaban tratar se medican en el
exterior por razones de turismo tenían
que venir acá al banco central del
ecuador realizar los justificativos
necesarios y obtener los dólares pero
hasta ese entonces se permite ya hacer
operación todas las familias los hogares
las empresas comienzan a operar en en
dólares
entonces otro de los elementos clave es
que se da para para ir dándose este
proceso de la tradición es el tema de
los desequilibrios monetarios que se da
básicamente a partir de la mitad de los
años 90 estos desequilibrios monetarios
se dan
básicamente explicado por un tema de que
ciertas instituciones financieras entran
en problemas
por un lado entonces recurren a
necesidades de liquidez y una función
clave que tienen los bancos al tales
emisores de dinero es de ser
prestamistas de última instancia qué
significa esto obviamente un banco que
tiene problemas de liquidez nuevo de
solvencia
acude al banco central y el banco ser
como ese emisor puede tener la
posibilidad de hacer eso
ciertas instituciones que no teniendo
problemas de solvencia solamente
liquidez también recurren a está porque
porque no obstante que pueden estar
sólidos el tema solamente de los ruidos
que pueden haber de las corridas que
pueden haber puede
provocar problemas inclusive a los
bancos más sólidos y fuertes del país
esto sucede en todas partes del mundo
entonces la posibilidad de que se da ese
tipo de problemas hace que la gente
comienza también a tener desconfianza en
el sistema financiero y comienza a
retirar recursos del sistema financiero
y el banco central comienza a hacer
obviamente ser los de prestamista de
última instancia para esto
ya es dólar como les decía los bancos
nacionales en deuda con el exterior en
moneda extranjera en dólares y los
bancos obviamente tienen que prestar en
dólares a la economía interna las
empresas que a su vez en deuda con los
bancos también tienen que vender en
dólar los precios de los bienes y
servicios algunos los precios de ciertos
bienes ya se comienzan a expresar en
dólares clic ese entonces las casas los
departamentos las oficinas los
consultorios se expresan en dólares
ciertos de electrodomésticos también se
expresan en dólares y también los autos
se expresan en dólares entonces ya hay
justo hasta que está una foto de de un
carrito que yo me compré en 1997 y que
hasta ahora fluye perfectamente por la
ciudad de quito
yo me compré este este auto en mil en
marzo del 97 cuando el tipo de cambio
estaba estable y la tasa de interés era
tres veces menor que en sucres 15% en
dólares en su que es 45 decisión
racional de los agentes de endeudarse en
dólares
entonces yo pagaba una cuota de 243
dólares el equivalente a 900 mil sucres
yo ganaba en sucres y podía obviamente
reunir cada mes los 243 ningún problema
pero esta vez se me fue complicando doy
un ejemplo mío pero fue es una
transición que se transformó en forma
general al final fijase de la
dolarización los 243 dólares significó
pagar 6 millones de sucres mensuales
básicamente por la depreciación entonces
cuáles son los defectos de la creación
excesiva de dinero cuando hay más
oferta de bienes de productos de precio
baja igual sucede con la moneda cuando
hay un excesivo de cantidad de dinero en
moneda nacional en este caso obviamente
se traduce en devaluación inflación y
obviamente en la pérdida de las
funciones del sucre el su rol de dinero
que vamos a explicar a continuación
entonces el tipo de cambio se nos va
complicando especialmente a fines del
año de los 90 antes necesita cuando el
banco central sigue defendiendo un tipo
de cambio a través de lo que se llama
las bandas cambiarias
teníamos un dólar significaba 10.000
azúcar cuando abandona el tipo de cambio
fijo a través de las bandas el tipo de
cambio se sitúa en 20.000 ya les voy a
un poco de terror tomás de este tema
pero acá es importante que que veamos el
tema de la conexión que hay entre entre
lo que pasa en inflación y la
devaluación ahí está una foto de mi
carrera
real en corte en que encontré en el
internet
si la casera en ecuador es a la persona
que frecuentemente le compramos en
méxico se llama marchante etcétera no
entonces cuando yo iban de la casera con
la familia a comprar cada semana las
verduras las frutas le decíamos casera
porque me sube los precios de las frutas
ira y violencia porque no hay ninguna
situación real que explique la subida no
hay inundaciones no hay sequías no hay
ningún prueba no hay ningún programa y
la casera me decía no veis lo que está
pasando con el dólar
entonces la casera y toda la población
de liga vamos tanto lo que está pasando
con el dolor y rápidamente la
transformados en azúcar y el tipo de
cambio obviamente si gris se disparaba
sí entonces ahí esa conexión que se
explica desde la teoría monetaria
inclusive a partir de la famosa teoría
de la paridad de poder de compra sí
entonces eso genera fíjese también un
deterioro de la capacidad
de compras de los ecuatorianos los
precios comienzan a dispararse los
salarios pueden subir
pero en términos reales comienza a
disminuir entonces la gente cada vez se
le complica pero los salarios a finales
de los años 90 fíjese en la dolarización
informal es un punto fundamental si se
hace más se acelera los créditos se
expresan en dólares
en los depósitos la gente que todavía
confiado tenía necesidad de hacer tu
puesto lo hacía en dólares y había un
elemento fundamental y el colchón van la
gente ahorraba todos los dólares que
podía en su casa si recibe a sucre es
como había ese proceso devaluatorio lo
cambiaba rápidamente a adorar y guardaba
en el colchón banco ya luego nos tocó
esta imagen en el famoso modelo de
estimación cuánto era el colchón van a
inicios de la dolarización entonces qué
hace el banco central desde esta
perspectiva hay dos regímenes de tipo de
cambio fundamentales con ciertos
variantes pero básicamente yo me voy a
referir a los primero tenemos un tipo de
cambio fijo y un tipo de cambio flexible
tratamos de hacer todos los esfuerzos
para mantener el tipo de cambio fijo si
o si no le mantenemos en una en una
grada o si no le dejamos que el tipo de
cambio shock eso vemos cuáles son los
efectos para tener un tipo de cambio
fijo se requiere dos elementos
fundamentales
la convertibilidad de la moneda qué
significa eso que el banco cental debe
estar dispuestos a entregar todos los
dólares que necesita la gente sí sino
caso contrario aparecen los mercados
paralelos en los mercados negros segundo
que debe tener las suficientes reservas
internacionales para defender ese tipo
de campo como yo les decía en la época
decía de la crisis
el tipo de cambio su día o sea había un
elemento político adverso el tipo de
cambio subía había una inducción una
inundación el tipo de cambio subía había
una serie del tipo de cambio se subía
perdía la liga el tipo de cambio subía
es decir todos los elementos hacían que
el tipo de cambio suba entonces cuando
el banco central ya no tiene las
suficientes reservas abandona la defensa
del tipo de cambio en mayo de 99 a una
constelación de 10.000 y le dice la
población si ustedes quieren dólares
compren en el mercado el tipo de cambio
vez que se fije en el mercado
entonces conocía el problema de xperia
de reservas y le dejamos prestar no hay
problemas de inflación y si esto se
producen más desequilibrios generados
desde el aspectos monetarios o fiscales
nos puede producir una crisis de pagos
es decir una crisis en que el ecuador no
puede enfrentar con sus obligaciones
externas y después puede también generar
hiperinflación algunos casos del mundo
estamos sufriendo entonces en ese tiempo
se discutía varios esquemas al sistema
de la aviación el tema de la
convertibilidad el tema de seguir en una
moneda para hacer políticas de ajustes
para más
tratar de controlar hay ejemplos que
lograron controlar a pesar de haber
países con fútbol oralización como el
caso de bolivia entonces requisitos para
la donación que nos decía la academia de
la literatura existente en ese tiempo
que debe un país para que dólar y se
debe requerir estabilidad macroeconómica
estaba una disciplina fiscal fíjese
necesitamos disciplina monetaria y
necesitamos sanidad en el sistema
financiero entonces nosotros decíamos en
el banco central con algunas colegas si
tenemos eso para qué vamos a dolarizar
no tiene sentido pero eso nos pedía la
literatura de hacen tiempos porque
porque no hay muchas experiencias en el
mundo entonces a partir de la decisión
oficial del presidente mawat la única
moneda legalmente permitida es el dólar
de eeuu desaparece el sucre todos los
precios se expresan en dólares de los
estados unidos se prohíbe al banco
central del ecuador emitir moneda
nacional salvo moneda fraccionaria para
evitar el redondeo y que la casera no me
suba más de precios entonces eso de
implementación de la dolarización
todos fíjese tenemos por un lado cuáles
son las obligaciones monetarias del
banco central la misión los depósitos
del sistema financiero en el central los
depósitos del hubieron el central
etcétera esas son mis obligaciones de
sucs y que tengo tengo dólares entonces
más o menos tenemos 850 millones de
dólares de libre disponibilidad y de
pasivos teníamos 21 millones de sucres
es decir 21 más 12 ceros entonces eso
pudimos cambiar a la cotización de 25
mil sucres
no puedo segundo la 25 mil porque no hay
no hay esa ese billete pero tenemos en
cuenta equivalía a 2 a 2 dólares todos
para responder a la pregunta inicial
porque ese dureza ecuador básicamente yo
diría porque sucre perdió sus funciones
de dinero que atribuye la teoría
monetaria qué significa eso ya nos
sirvió como medio de pago nos sirvió
como unidad de cuenta porque los precios
ya se expresaban en su en dólares fue
más aún después del valor tenemos el
colchón van entonces el choque para nada
y va teniendo eso se perdió el tema de
la aceptación general aquí el mensaje es
que más allá de las decisiones de los
estados de los gobiernos es la gente que
percibe que moneda va a mantener
mientras tanto le permita cumplir con
sus obligaciones o como sus funciones
como dinero hasta aquí en mi
presentación muchas gracias